C'est une scène surréaliste qui s'est
produite cette nuit
dans le quartier Saint-Jacques de Beaune, pourtant réputé tranquille.
Vers 1h30 cette nuit, un véhicule fou
a foncé délibérément
sur un groupe de jeunes qui jouait à la console et discutait juste ici derrière moi
blessant trois personnes qui tentaient de fuir.
Trois heures plus tard vers 4h30,
un autre véhicule s'arrête.
Le passager descend et tire au fusil de chasse, blessant sept jeunes.
Écoutez cette habitante du quartier qui est venue immédiatement porter secours à ses voisins :
"Je suis descendue puisque j'ai entendu pleurer.
'Appelez les pompiers, appelez les
pompiers'.
Et en effet il y avait des blessés.
Ça, je comprends pas.
C'est la première fois que ça arrive.
Il n'y a jamais de problèmes dans le quartier,
vous voyez c'est calme."
Parmi les sept blessés, un est dans
un état grave et il a été transféré au CHU de Dijon.
On ignore les motifs de cette agression mais
dans le quartier on parle de motifs racistes.
Écoutez cet ami des victimes qui les a
joints par téléphone :
"Les blessés ne parlent pas de règlements
de comptes. Ils parlent de racistes.
C'est des gens qui sont venus dans le
quartier en les insultant de bougnoules.
C'est des racistes, ils cherchaient la bagarre tout simplement.
Ils ont dit qu'ils allaient revenir
avec un fusil.
Ils sont venus et ils ont tiré."
L'enquête a été confiée conjointement
au commissariat de Beaune et à la PJ de Dijon.
Les caméras de vidéo surveillance
présentes dans le quartier
permettront peut-être
d'identifier les auteurs.